PROFESSOR: Everyone
seems to be here.
At least all the seats
are filled up, so
why don't we begin.
One thing that I did finally,
to be specific, I told you
that we would have three quizzes
and that they would be
uniformly spaced one third, and
2/3 and 2.89 thirds of the
way through the term.
And I figured out where
those dates would be.
So since I have them, let
me give you the date.
So Quiz 1 is going to be
on Thursday, October 6.
Quiz 2 will be on Tuesday,
November 8, and Quiz 3 will be
on Thursday, December 8.
And this, as advertised, is
exactly one third of the way
through the lectures.
This is exactly 2/3 of the way
through the lectures, and this
is the next to the last meeting
that we'll have.
This is the week before the
final week of the terms. so I
deliberately kept it a little
bit away from the usual
end-of-term crunch.
Being person who is sensitive to
symmetry and order, I find
it highly regrettable that
we cannot have the
quiz on October 8.
Then you would on the 8th of
October, November, December,
you have a quiz.
Unfortunately, October 8, much
as that would beautify the
schedule, is on a Saturday,
so we can't do it so.
I could do it, but I don't
think anybody would come.
I've been, believe it or not,
going through these problem
sets in great detail.
I didn't want to hand them out
until I had the list--
and you may or may not know--
that is made up for the
registrants in each class, And
we get a nice array of
photographs with names and
department numbers and years
numbers under them.
That something, by the way, that
only the instructor in a
class requests, not even the
secretary can do it.
So this is not widely
broadcast.
I found to my dismay though
when I finally got it that
about one third of the
pictures are missing.
And I don't know whether you
folks have been photographed
fairly late on the term,
but a third of the
pictures are missing.
I already been putting some
faces in my memory banks, but
to match up names and faces
so that I can hand out the
problem sets individually,
I need more photographs.
So I'll do it one way or another
next time, and we'll
see some photographs, additional
photographs, have
appeared in the interim.
I've given you three problem
sets so far, and they were
really just for fun as well as
to get you thinking about the
right sorts of things, but
there were little puzzle.
I'm, unfortunately, going to
have to tell you from now on
no more cutesy little puzzles.
You're going to get
real problem sets,
long, tedious, drudgery.
They're optional though, so
that's the saving grace.
So I'm going to pass it around
the problem set 4.
And this asks you to demonstrate
some of the things
that we talked about last time
and convince yourself that
they really work and ask
you to make some simple
applications of Miller-Bravais
indices to
two-dimensional lattices.
And then finally, the last
problem is to get you thinking
about patterns.
And I've asked you to identify
the lattice points and the
symmetry elements
in two patterns.
I'm almost willing to wager that
not one of you will get
it completely right, that
there's going to be some
little thing that you
missed or did wrong.
At one time, I bet a bag of
potato chips for everybody in
the class against the class
wagering against me one bag of
potato chips.
Well, I'm going to watch my
weight, and I've won that
invariably, and I really can't
eat that greasy sort of stuff.
In any case, you'll see that
in the case of symmetry and
patterns it is immensely
simplified when you know
exactly what to look for, when
you know the number of
possibilities was finite,.
And when we're through with
this, you can ask just one
question about a pattern and
then know exactly what the
symmetry of that pattern has
to be and exactly where to
look for everything else.
I can guarantee you that by the
time you finish this class
you will never sit in a bathroom
and stare at the tile
floor and see it in exactly
the same way again.
I think that's a good
observation because I like to
think that that's what education
is all about, not
sitting in the bathroom, but
seeing things differently
after you've had the experience
than you did before.
That's what education
is all about.
So have fun with the patterns.
And again, it will become--
one seat up here.
Today then we're about ready
to embark on an adventure.
As I said last time, we'll
develop two-dimensional
symmetries first because there
are relatively few of them,
and one could do
this rigorously
and in great detail.
We're going to have to touch on
things more lightly when we
get to three-dimensional
symmetries so we can finish at
a decent point in the term.
Let me remind you that we have
so far identified two types of
symmetry that can exist in a
lattice, onefold, twofold,
threefold, or sixfold
rotation axes.
Any number of different
rotational symmetries are
possible, but if you're going to
want them to be compatible
with a lattice, you must
restrict the rotation axis to
one of these five, including
a onefold axis, which is no
symmetry it all.
And in two-dimensions, besides
translation, we saw the
operation of reflection.
And now we're going to begin
to put things together and
make elaborate combinations.
The first thing I will ask is
can we have more than one of
these symmetry elements present
and operating about
the same locus at
the same time.
The answer to that would
be, why not.
Because if we look at a sixfold
rotation axis, that's
really what a twofold rotation
axis does combined with what a
threefold rotation axis does.
And we plot these on top of one
another, and what we end
up with is the arrangement of
motifs that is generated by
sixfold axis.
So in a sense, a sixfold axis is
a twofold axis superimposed
on a threefold axis.
That kind of a naive way about
thinking of this though.
What we're really saying is that
what a sixfold axis has
is the set of operations 1 A
2 pi/ 6, A twice 2 pi /6 --
that would be 120 degree
rotation--
and A pi, A 5 pi/6.
And there's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
And we're missing one.
60, 120, 240.
So that would be A twice
2 pi/3, 4 pi/6
So what we're really saying is
a sixfold axis consists of
these six elements, and these
elements constitute a group
because I can combine any two
of these rotation operations
and find something that's
already a member of the set.
By saying that a sixfold axis
consists of a threefold axis
sitting on top of a twofold
axis, what we're saying is
that there's one collection
of elements here, namely
identity, or same thing as A 2
pi and A pi, that is a subset
of these, or we could
say a subgroup.
So what we're doing in saying
that these two sets of
rotation operations exist
simultaneously, we're saying
that the twofold axis is a
subgroup of the sixfold axis.
And similarly, we can separate
out three other elements, a
onefold axis, same as A 2 pi;
a 120-degree rotation, A 2
pi/3; and a 240-degree
rotation, A 4 pi/3.
And these three operations,
a group of rank 2, is what
constitutes another subgroup, a
subset of elements which by
themselves satisfy all of the
requirements of a group.
So this is one example of how
we can have more than one
symmetry element, a set of
operations existing about the
same locus and space.
This is not how one would go
about the deriving these
higher symmetry however.
Because what we have to do is
to add something to the set,
something that's called an
extender, and then show that
all the requirements of a set
being a group is satisfied;
namely, that a combination of
any two elements in the group
is also a member the group, that
for every operation an
inverse exists, and the identity
operation is a member
of the group.
So you can build up more
higher symmetries, more
complex symmetries by adding
some operation called an
extender and then taking all
of the products of these
elements and see what new
operations arise.
So we can have more than one
symmetry element operating
about the same locus and the set
of individual operations
that it embodies.
And here sitting all by itself
is a mirror plane.
Why don't we combine a mirror
plane with the rotation axis?
And we've already seen
examples of that.
For example, in the square
pattern that these tiles make
up, there's a fourfold axis in
the middle of each of the
squares that are also mirror
planes that pass
through that location.
So let me look at a combination
that is a little
simpler to handle.
And what I'm going to say is
here sits a mirror plane with
a reflection operation that
I'll call sigma 1 for the
individual operation.
And let me say that I combine
now in that space a second
reflection operation
about a line that
intersects the first one.
And the question I'm going to
ask now is happens when I take
a first motif, number 1,
reflected in the locus of the
first mirror plane to get number
2, and then reflect
that a second time in the locus
of the second mirror
plane to get one that
sits up here.
So the question is now what is
the operation sigma 1 followed
by the operation sigma
2 equals to?
We can almost answer by the
process of elimination.
If this one is left handed,
reflection changes the
polarity, so number
2 is right hand.
And if we reflect a second time,
the right-handed one
goes to a left-handed one.
So what we're asking is how do
I get from one left-handed
motif to another left-handed
motif?
Of the three operations that
exist in a two-dimensional
space could be translation.
But, clearly, I can't take the
first one and slide it
parallel to itself and make it
coincide with the third.
So translation would not change
chirality, but that
won't work.
What's left?
Rotation.
Yes.
You want to clarify
something first?
AUDIENCE: That third one, it
looks kind of left-handed.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oops.
It does.
It does indeed.
Sorry about that.
When you've got your nose poked
right in these things,
it's easy to overlook it.
Yes.
Absolutely right.
That should be over canted over
a bit more like I had it
the first way.
Very good thank you.
I don't want to proceed much.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What did
you [INAUDIBLE]
axis [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: We could do that.
And let's do it, and we're
going to encounter
this sooner or later.
So we have a first mirror plane
reflect from a first
one, which is right handed, to
second one that's left handed.
And then define a second locus,
and that one would take
the second one and move it
over to here, the same
distance on the other side
of this mirror plane.
And I'll let you answer the
question since you asked it.
How is the first one related
to the third one?
AUDIENCE: Translation.
PROFESSOR: Translation.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It's translated.
PROFESSOR: Exactly So if this
distance is delta, the first
and the third are related
be a translation
which is twice delta.
So that would be in addition
where we'll eventually want to
consider when we have patterns
that are based on a lattice.
But right now, I want to
consider symmetry operations
that leave at least a point in
space and move perhaps a line
in the case of the
mirror plane.
But back to the original
question, what is this first
reflection followed by
a second reflection?
We've just thrown
out translation.
That won't work unless the
mirror planes are parallel to
one of those.
The only thing left
is rotation.
And in point of fact, even
looking at this diagram, you
can get from the first one to
the third one by a rotation.
So the answer to the question
is that a combination of two
reflection operations is a
rotation operation about the
point of intersection of
the mirror planes.
But we can go further and say
exactly how large this
rotation is.
Let's draw an extra
line in here.
And let's say that this
angle is alpha.
And if I repeat this
by reflection, that
angle is also alpha.
Let's label this angle beta.
Repeat that by reflection, and
that angle must also be beta.
The angle between the two mirror
planes is the angle mu.
And clearly mu is equal
to alpha plus beta.
So the answer to the question
quite generally is have two
mirror planes intersect at an
angle mu, and their successive
operation is going to be
equivalent to the net result
of rotating through
twice of the angle
between them mirror line.
So we don't have to think
about that anymore now.
We know if we combine
to mirror planes
we get a net rotation.
So that is a basic result, and
that's a first example of
something that I'm going to
call by my own pet term.
I'm going to call them
combination theorem, the
theorem that tells you what you
get when you combine two
operations.
And what this is going to give
us is a way of filling in one
box in the group multiplication
table.
So knowing what two mirror
planes combined at an angle
should be, I can now combine
the mirror planes at angles
which gives me a rotation
operation which is one of the
ones that's allowed
for a lattice.
In general, if I'm not yet
putting these symmetry
elements in a lattice, I could
combine them in such a way
such that I got a 17-fold
rotation as the angle.
And then the angle between
the mirror planes would
be half of 2 pi/17.
Could be a lovely symmetry, nice
for a pendant or a ring,
but not for a lattice and
not for a crystal.
So I'm going to want to combine
mirror planes at
angles that correspond to
rotations that are compatible
with the lattice.
So what I could do is take
a first reflection
locus, sigma 1.
And if I want the rotation angle
to be 180 degrees for a
twofold axis, I would want the
second mirror plane with the
operation sigma 2 to be
at one half of pi with
respect to the first.
And for this specific
combination then, reflection
in the first mirror planes
followed by reflection in the
second mirror planes to give me
a third one, is going to be
equivalent to--
Oops.
Back here--
it's going to be equivalent
to a twofold axis.
So sigma 1 followed by sigma 2
at an angle one half of pi is
going to be equivalent to the
rotation operation A pi.
This is not yet a complete
pattern because here's a
mirror planes that wants to
reflect this motifs as well.
So let's just reflect number 3
across the mirror planes 1.
And then we're going to
get a fourth object.
Now let's show that this
constitutes a group.
We've got the identity operation
doing nothing.
We've got the operation
sigma 1.
sigma 2, and we've got
the operation a pi.
I'll put the same operations
again in the vertical column.
Here's operation 1 doing
nothing, sigma 1,
sigma 2, and A pi.
So doing nothing and following
it by one of these four
operations just gives you the
same thing back again.
And doing these operations
followed by 1 will give me the
same operation back again.
If I reflect twice across sigma
1 from left to right and
right to left, I'm back to
where I started from.
So sigma 1 followed by sigma 1
is the identity operation.
Sigma 1 followed by sigma
2 is what we just did.
That turns out to be
the operation A pi.
And sigma 1 reflection and
following that by A pi is the
way in which I get to
the fourth one.
So that is going to be
equal to sigma 2.
Well, let me rips through the
last ones fairly quickly.
Sigma 2 followed by signal 1.
Sigma 2 followed by sigma
1 is the same as A pi.
Sigma 2 followed by sigma 2
gets us back to where we
started from.
That's the identity operation.
Sigma 2 followed by A pi reflect
from here to here and
then rotate.
That's the same as sigma 1.
And the final sequence,
rotation followed by
reflection would give
me sigma 2.
Rotation followed by sigma
2 will give me sigma 1.
And doing the rotation operation
twice is the same as
the identity operation.
So are the group postulates
satisfied?
Yes.
The combination of any
two elements is a
member of the group.
For every operation,
an inverse exists.
And we can answer that question
very easily by merely
looking at the column under
a particular element, and
somewhere we find the
identity operation.
So sigma 1 is its own inverse.
So, yes, an inverse exists
for every operation.
And then finally, identity
is a member of the group.
So everything's lights up.
Bells ring.
This set of four elements
is entitled to
call itself a group.
And in particular, it is a group
of rank 4 because there
are four elements
in the group.
I show you a cool thing.
I noticed that the number of
objects in the pattern, the
number of motifs in the pattern,
is exactly the same
as the order of the group.
Why?
Because these four operations
tell you how to get from any
operation to the remaining three
and tell you how to get
it into itself.
So identity relates
it to itself.
Sigma 1 reflects it to here.
A pi rotates it down to here.
Sigma 2 reflects it
down to here.
So there's always a one-to-one
correspondence between the
elements that are in the group
and the rank of a group and
the number of objects that
are in the pattern.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: How do you show if
the inverse exists again?
PROFESSOR: The inverse exists
if I can find something that
combined with an element in
my basic set gives me the
identity operation.
So it's the operation followed
by its inverse has to be the
same as doing nothing.
So if I look under each element
and find the identity
operation, then sigma 2
is its own inverse.
If I look under A pi, A
pi is its own inverse.
This is generally
not the case.
This is a very simple
symmetry.
So really we can work with
commas and little figures, and
that's one way of getting
these symmetries.
But group theory I think you can
see is a very nice, very
elegant language for
describing some
characteristics of
these patterns.
Now little bit of jargon.
As if this material were not
confusing enough, there are
two different languages that
are used to denote these
unique combinations.
This notation where we simply
have a number for a rotation
axis or an m for mirror plane
is something that was first
proposed by two
mathematicians, Hermann and Mauguin.
And this was adopted as the
preferred notation in the
international tables, that hefty
tome that I brought it
on the first day of classes.
So this is also referred
to synonymously as the
international notation.
Let me put these things
out horizontally.
For rotation axes by themselves,
the symbol in
Hermann notation is simply n.
And for lattice, n--
as we've seen many times--
is restricted to what in
Hermann-Mauguin notation would
be either 1, 2, 3, 4, and 6.
There's another type of notation
that is use quite
frequently by condensed matter
physicist, and this is called
the Schoenflies notation after
one of the mathematicians who
was the first to derive the
three-dimensional symmetries.
This was a curious thing.
There were three people in
different parts of the world
about the turn of the century--
and this was before
email or even air mail--
who were trying to derive the
three-dimensional symmetries.
Schoenflies was one of them.
And all three of them got to
the same place at about the
same time, and the results
were obtained.
But each one used his
own method and had
his different notation.
Schoenflies was one of the
people who did this.
Schoenflies was a mathematician
and based his
notation on group theory.
Something called a cyclic
group is what
the C stands for.
And a cyclic group is one in
which all elements are power,
so to speak, of some
basic operation.
For example, a fourfold axis
consists of the set of
operations A pi/2; a 90 degree
rotation; A pi, which can be
written as A pi over 2 squared;
A pi over 2 squared;
[? then we need ?]
A pi/2; and A pi/ 2 again; A 3
pi/2, which can be viewed as
doing A pi/2 three times; and
finally, the identity
operation, which is the same as
A 2 pi, which is equivalent
to doing the basic operation
A pi/2 four times.
So the group of rank 4, there
are four elements in the
group, each one is a power of
the basic operation A pi/2.
So a rotation axis by itself
as a cyclic group.
Schoenflies indicates these
generically by C subscript n,
where n is the rank
of the axis.
Hence, this is C1.
This is C2.
This is C3.
This is C4.
And this is C6.
A mirror plane by itself
is indicated m in the
international notation.
A mirror plane is also
a cyclic group.
There are two operations,
reflection and reflection back
to where you came from.
Doing the reflection operation
twice is the
same as doing nothing.
So Schoenflies also call this
one C. And the one thing that
is without meaning in English
is his subscript S. And
Schoenflies was German, and
the S stands for spiegel,
which is the German
word for mirror.
We have in many cities
a paper that's
called the Daily Mirror.
In Germany, there's a paper
called Der Spiegel.
So they use it the same
way in everyday life
as well as in notation.
So C sub S in the Schoenflies
notation is a mirror plane.
Cyclic group the S stand
for spiegel.
For the combinations of which we
have seen only one, in the
Schoenflies notation these are
all of the form Cnv, a
rotation axis Cn with a vertical
mirror plane passing
through it.
So this one, for example--
we've yet
to look at the others--
would be C2v.
So we'll have to draw the first,
and then I'll give you
the complete set.
So this is a rotation axis with
a mirror plane passing
vertically through it.
Let's do a few more.
And I think having done a couple
in great detail, we'll
see what the others will look
like quite readily.
Let's take a fourfold axis and
add to the rotation operations
A pi/2, a first mirror plane
that I'll label sigma 1.
I can permute the order of
operations and say that sigma
1 followed by the rotation
operation A pi/2 is going to
be equal to a second reflection
operation that is
equal to one half of pi/2
away from the first.
So I'm claiming that if I
reflect in the first mirror
plane and then rotate by 90
degrees that should be another
mirror plane at 45 degrees
to the first.
So let me do exactly
what I advertised.
Here's the first, one
right handed.
Reflect across to get a second
one, which is left handed.
Reflect, then rotate, and that
would bring my left-handed one
up to this location here.
So here's 3, and it's
left handed.
And lo and behold, just as
advertised, I get from the
first one to the third one by
reflecting across a mirror
plane, which is one
half of pi/2.
If let these symmetry elements
operate on each other, what
I'll end up with is a
set of mirror planes
at 45 degree intervals.
And what I'll have is a pair
of objects hung in the same
fashion at every mirror plane.
Is that too fast?
You want to go through
that a little slower?
Oh, go ahead say, go through
it more slowly.
Everybody's afraid to say, yeah,
yeah, and been seem like
a class dummy.
Do you want me to do
it more slowly?
I see people still writing, so I
think what you'd rather have
is me be quiet for a bit while
you catch up to where I am.
In the Schoenflies notation,
this lovely thing here is C4.
It's a rotation axis of rank 4
with a vertical mirror plane
added to it.
And the international
notation, now the
Hermann-Mauguin notation, is
just a running list of the
individual symmetry elements
that are present.
And now I really are going
to have a mouthful.
This is a fourfold axis, so
the symbol for that is 4.
This is a mirror plane.
That's a mirror plane, and
that's a mirror plane.
So it looks as though I should
call this 4mmmmmmmm, which
comes 4mmmmmmmm.
Well, that is a typical
reaction.
It's a lovely symmetry.
But that is a mouthful.
So it isn't really necessary to
give all these m's So the
international notation is
a running list of the
independent symmetry elements,
and that's the new wrinkle
that I'm introducing.
It's a running list of the
independent symmetry elements.
And all these mirror planes are
just different sigma that
exist as operations
in the group.
But how many different kinds
of mirror planes are they?
Well, there are two different
kinds of mirror planes, both
in terms of the way in which
they function in the pattern.
The two motifs related by
reflection hang close to this
mirror plane, but they're widely
separated for this
mirror plane.
So the motifs do different
things relative to those two
kinds of mirror planes.
Another way of asking what's
independent is if I start with
this 1 mirror plane and repeat
it by 90-degree rotations,
I'll get these 4 mirror planes
90 degrees away.
So they are not independent in
that these mirror planes are
all related by the rotational
symmetry that's present.
You don't get this mirror plane
in any fashion other
than saying, if I combine the
rotation operation with this
reflection operation sigma,
the net result is this
reflection plane.
So there are two mirror planes
that are distinct in this
arrangement of symmetry
elements, distinct in the
sense that they function in
different ways in the pattern;
distinct in the sense that no
other operation that is
present will throw these two
operations into one another.
Another example, and this is in
fact symmetry 4mm, is the
square tile.
If you look at the mirror planes
there, they are 45
degrees apart.
But one of those mirror planes
comes out normal to the edge
of the tile.
The other mirror plane comes out
of the vertex of the tile.
So they are different in the way
they function in the space
which has this symmetry.
So, mercifully, we don't have
to call this 4mmmmmmmm.
We drop the last 6 m's, and this
one is called simply for
4mm, 2 kinds of mirror planes
with a fourfold axis.
If you're familiar with the
way in which these were
derived, the symbol tells you
exactly what you've got.
So it's a very useful notation
for these symmetries.
Let me pause here, give you
a chance to catch up.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: So wait, all you did
here is take two separate
mirror planes at an angle of
45 degrees between, and you
ended up with a fourfold
symmetry.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: But you didn't put on
the fourfold symmetry, it
was just what fell out of it?
PROFESSOR: No.
I Got this mirror plane to begin
with by combining this
reflection operation sigma with
the operation A pi/2, and
that's where this operation
came from.
But a general theorem that
says if I have a rotation
operation A alpha and combine it
with a reflection operation
sigma, the combined effect is
a reflection operation sigma
2, which is alpha/2 away
from the first.
So, again, showing you for this
now rather messy diagram,
if I start with the reflection
operation that takes 1 of them
throws of the 2 and then rotates
2 up to location 3,
the way I get from 1 to 3 in one
shot is to reflect in this
locus sigma 2.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: You could have started
with any one of those
two and got the third.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
The operations that are
present operate
everything in the space.
So when I say that there's a
mirror plane here that relates
this one to this one, it also
relates this one to this one,
this one to this one, this one
to this one, that mirror
planes operates on everything.
You can't say that a symmetry
operation grab this little
packet of space and moves
it to another packet
removed from it.
To say it's a symmetry of a
pattern or of a crystal, it
has to leave everything
invariant.
OK.
But, again, in terms of the
language of groups theory, if
you combine this pair of
operations, then when you
combine everything that you get
pairwise, you will get in
this case a total of,
how many operations?
How many operations are
in this pattern?
I said a moment ago the rank of
the group is the number of
operations that are present.
It's the number of objects that
are in the group because
each operation in a group tells
you how to get from
anyone to all of the other.
So, 2, 4, 6, 8, this is a group
of rank 8, and there are
8 operation that are present.
And I can rattle them
off quickly.
Four operations, identity,
90, 180, 270 for
the fourfold axis.
That's 4.
This mirror plane.
The mirror plane.
And this mirror plane.
That's 8.
Four for rotation.
Four for reflection.
Other questions?
All right.
Let me then wrap up this
quickly and get
onto something new.
Did I hear the hiccup
or a question?
No.
It was a hiccup.
Not a yawn I hope.
Let me do the highest symmetry
of all in two dimensions, and
this is if I take a sixfold
axis and combine it with a
mirror plane.
So here's the first
operation sigma.
This one is something
of a bear to draw.
This is sigma 1.
Sigma 1 followed by the
operation A 2 pi/6 should be
equal to a reflection that is an
angle one half of 2 pi/6 30
degrees away from the first.
So this will be sigma 2.
So if I reflect from 1 to 2 and
then rotate by 60 degrees,
I'm going to get one
that sets up here.
And the way I get from number
1 to number 3 in one shot is
by a reflection sigma 2.
Now if I draw in all of those
are mirror planes when they
are repeated by the sixfold
axis, I shouldn't have given
this my 6mmmmmm treatment
because there
are 12 mirror planes.
Two objects hanging on this one
in one fashion spaced in a
different way that are
belly to belly.
They're back to back here, so it
does something different in
the pattern.
A pair hanging here.
A pair hanging in here.
A pair hanging and here.
And finally, a pair
hanging in here.
So there are a total
2, 4, 6, 8, 10, 12
motifs in this pattern.
Pairs hanging on mirror planes
that are 30 degrees apart and
hanging disposed and pointing
in different ways on the
adjacent mirror planes.
So this is one that we would
call in international notation
6mmm and in Schoenflies
notation C6v.
So we're making extraordinary
progress here.
The one that I did for you
initially was C2v, and that's
2mn in international notation.
The only one that I left out to
this point is a threefold
axis compared with a vertical
mirror planes.
And let's start with the
operation A 2 pi/3, combined
with that a first reflection
operation sigma 1 that passes
through it.
And for reference, I'll drawn
in some lines that are
separated by intervals
of 60 degrees.
So this reflection from 1 to 2
followed by a rotation 120
degrees should give me
this one as number 3.
The first is right handed.
The second is left handed, and
the third stays left handed.
And lo and behold, the way I get
from 1 to 3 directly is by
a reflection sigma 2 across
a mirror line that is--
I'm sorry.
This is number 1 down here--
across a mirror line that is
30 degrees away from
the first.
If I would complete the pattern,
reflect this one
across to here, take this pair
and reflect it or rotate it up
here, and I have six objects.
So this is a group of rank 6.
And it has characteristics that
are quite analogous to
those we did for the other
rotation axes in all respect
except one.
The international symbol for
this combination is C3v.
We've got a threefold axis.
We've got the mirror plane
that we added.
And then we've got a mirror
plane that is 30 degrees away
from the first--
I'm sorry--
60 degrees away from the first,
one half of 120 degrees.
I claim that this is not the
proper symbol because the
mirror planes that are
listed should be the
symmetry-independent, distinct
sort of mirror planes.
And is that the case
with this one?
The answer is no.
It isn't.
Here is one mirror plane.
It's got a pair of motifs
hanging on it.
This mirror plane here is a
mirror plane that has a pair
of motifs hanging it.
Same is true of this
mirror plane.
So all six of these mirror
planes are doing the same
thing in the pattern.
Each one has a pair of a motifs
on either side of it in
the same fashion.
And I can get one mirror plane
and the motifs hanging on it
by a rotation of 120 degrees.
So there's only one kind of
mirror planes, so we don't
need that m.
So all of the other rotational
symmetries, m, a onefold axis
with a mirror plane; 2mm,
4mm, 6mm have two
kinds of mirror planes.
C3v has only one kind
of mirror planes.
And another way of showing
that is if I look at a
trigonal prism.
It's got a mirror plane coming
out of a corner and out of the
opposite face.
Mirror plane coming out
of the corner and out
the opposite face.
Mirror plane coming out
of a corner and out
the opposite face.
And that's exactly the
rearrangement of symmetry
elements here.
So each mirror planes when
drawn in relative to a
trigonal prism, which is a body
that has this symmetry,
each mirror planes does exactly
the same thing, as
opposed to the square tile or
square prism that has one kind
of mirror plane that comes out
of faces and one kind of
mirror plane that comes
out of corners.
So there are two different
types of mirror planes.
Let's add them all up,
summarize, and we've got the
cast of characters that we
can be use in deriving
two-dimensional symmetries.
We've got C1, which is a onefold
axis; C2, twofold
axis; C3, that's a threefold
axis; C4, and that's a
fourfold axis; C6, that's
a sixfold axis.
Then we've got the additions
that involve adding a mirror
plane to a rotational axis.
So this is simply m and CS
in Schoenflies notation.
Then we added a mirror plane
to a twofold axis.
We've got C2 with a vertical
mirror plane, 2mm; C3v; and
not 3mm, but only 3m; C4v, and
that's 4mm; and C6v, and
that's 6mm.
Add them all up, and there are
10 unique possibilities, no
more, no less.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: I'm missing a point.
Why is there the mirror plane
sigma 2 rather than rotating
sigma 1 is not different?
How do you?
PROFESSOR: The same thing is
going on, on this mirror plane
as on this mirror planes,
on this mirror plane.
Or if you like to see it in
terms of a geometric solid,
the mirror planes here in a
trigonal prism all of them do
the same thing.
They come out of one corner and
out of the opposite edge.
Each of these has one pair
of objects hanging on it.
And that is true of
all three of them.
And if you like, this end of
the mirror plane here is
nothing more than one that's
related to the first one by
one of the rotations of the
threefold axis extended back
in the opposite direction.
So the mirror plane doesn't
just work up here.
It works down here as well.
It works all through
the space.
So any way you want to look at
it and whatever terms work for
you, each of these mirror planes
is the same, but they
have a different type
of end to them.
There's something different
hanging at one end than
at the other end.
Think of it in terms of actual
physical object.
AUDIENCE: [? What about the ?]
case of the fourfold
[? there? ?]
PROFESSOR: In the fourfold,
one comes out of the face.
One comes out at the edge.
The motifs are oriented and
spaced at a different distance
from each of those neighboring
mirror planes.
So these two are different.
The fourfold axis never
rotates this
one into this one.
These two are not different
because the threefold axis
rotates, if you do it twice,
this end into this end of what
is one in the same mirror plane
as what's down on here.
So what's confusing you I
think is that there's a
polarity to the mirror planes.
Both ends of the mirror planes
do not have the same
disposition of motifs on them,
but there's nothing that says
that this has to be the case.
The motifs could just
be at one end.
And that, if you think about
it a little bit if it help,
figure out--
not on company time though, but
on your own time-- what a
fivefold axis does.
And a fivefold axis is a non
crystallographic symmetry.
But it turns out that C5v, which
is a 5 with an m, has
only one kind of mirror plane in
it as well and for exactly
the same reason.
A regular figure that has the
symmetry is a pentagon.
A mirror plane comes out
a corner and out of
the opposite face.
And that's true for all of the
mirror planes that are in
there and separated by
one half of 2 pi/5.
AUDIENCE: That's just whether or
not the [INAUDIBLE] axis is
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's what I said.
Yeah.
So before I go through all
of the rotation axes with
vertical mirror planes, the
international notation would
be 2mm, 3m, 4mm, 5m,
and 6mm, 7m.
For the odd symmetries, there's
only one kind of
mirror plane in a pattern,
in the tile, or
whatever you want to have.
So there are 10 distinct
possibilities, and these are
called the Point Groups.
Why?
Because they are clusters of
symmetry elements about at
least one point that's
fixed and embedded
immovably in space.
They're called groups because,
as we've seen for one simple
example, the collection of
operations follows the
postulates for the set of
elements which we have defined
as a group.
More specifically, we could
call these the 10
two-dimensional crystallographic
graphic Point
Groups, which is more
of a mouthful.
But it emphasizes the fact
that there are lots of
two-dimensional Point Groups,
but the two-dimensional
crystallographic Point Groups
are those that involve
rotational symmetry that are
compatible with a lattice.
Hence, they are
crystallographic.
But the number of Point Groups
is actually infinite if you
include the ones that are not
compatible with translation.
All right.
I think that's probably
a good place to quit.
And guess what?
My internal clock has told
me that this is the
time for our break.
This is one crossroads
in our development.
And what we'll do next for the
faint hearted who may not want
to have more of this stuff for
one day than what we've just
done, we're now going to do
the final penultimate
combination, and say we have
also shown that there are 5
two-dimensional lattices.
And the final step will be to
say if we have a pattern that
has symmetry and is based on
translation, we can obtain
these by taking each of the 10
crystallographic Point Groups
in turn and dropping them into
each of the five lattices that
can accommodate them.
We would not try, for example,
to take a Point Group like 4mm
and try to drop it into
the hexagonal lattice.
It's not going to fit.
But there will be two, maybe
three ways in which we can add
a given Point Group to one
of these lattice types.
And what we've done when
we finished is we have
exhaustively derived the
symmetries' translational
lattices and symmetry operations
of reflection and
rotation that are possible for
two-dimensional crystal.
You might say, well
two-dimensional crystal, I've
heard that people who do thin
film work to make monolayers
and really make a
two-dimensional crystal.
That's not something you could
say only a few years ago.
But why do we worry about
two-dimensional symmetries if
we're not to be wallpaper
designers?
Well, actually, I'll give
you one example.
One of the difficulties you had
in conveying the nature of
a crystal structure is taking
something that's fairly
complicated in three dimensions
and getting it onto
a two-dimensional
sheet of paper.
And what you invariably do is
you project the contents of
the unit cell down along
one of the cell edges.
And what you have then is a
two-dimensional crystal
structure with a lattice
and symmetry.
So you'll see two-dimensional
representations of
translationally periodic
arrangements of atoms quite
frequently when you look at
projections of actual crystal
structures, which is the only
reasonable way to convey the
information of any structure
once you get on beyond the
baby stuff of sodium chlorides,
zinc, sulfide and
body-centered iron.
OK.
I'm going to pause,
suck in air.
I am happy to turn you loose for
10 minutes and will meet
here again, let's say,
at 10 after 3:00.